that's good because i was making some
obscene noises
um
either way bro hum the love for
everything man
uh
salaam allah
it's been a whole week since we've gone
live eh
yeah yeah
so first thing i want to quickly get out
there quick psa before
uh we go into how everyone's doing is
alhamdulillah
will be our first ever live guest
yes you've heard it here first because
we've always done pre-recorded live um
or premieres
but this will be an actual legitimate
live stream this friday same time 7 p.m
eastern standard time uh but aside from
that man what is new with both of you
not guys to be honest i'm assembled you
know living learning alhamdulillah
honor man what are you doing in high
tester
all right all right so
off the rip we uh
have unfortunately due to high demand we
have way too many people in the waiting
room last time we tried this
so it will be open to members and
patreon members only so youtube members
and patreon members only if they want to
come and
you know
get a conversation with us
so i'm going to quickly post the link to
patreon and streamyod and one of the
other brothers inshaallah will take over
for a few moments
all right
let's uh let me hit you guys with a
little reminder insha allah that's a
good reminder i can give
him
there's one hadith i think i spoke about
it a few times but it's a very beautiful
hadith i was thinking about it recently
it's the hadith and usually you hear
either the first part of this hadith
the prophet
he
says the strong believer is better and
more beloved to allah than the weak
believer now what does it mean to be
strong there are many ways you can be
strong could be physically mentally
emotionally intellectually
strong with finances strong in many ways
so the the strong believer is better
more beloved to allah than the weak
believer why perhaps because they could
do more
and that kind of begs the question okay
how do you get strong
the process sent them in the
continuation of the hadith he says he
kind of answers that because he says
hold on to what gives you benefit or
cherish what brings you benefit
and trust in allah and do not lose your
heart like don't become hopeless
and then that begs the question okay
well you know what would make someone
become hopeless and then he answers that
too he says
if something comes to you in the form of
difficulty in the form of hardship
then don't say if only i did this or if
only i did that
and then you know so-and-so would have
happened or this wouldn't have happened
he said rather say
allah and allah this is what allah has
decreed and allah does as he wills and
then he says at the end because saying
if opens up the door to shaytan
that's the formula
[Music]
[Music]
seems a little uh awfully quiet today
man
yeah something about it maybe being a
monday bro
honestly man mondays are mondays are
just drags bro
how about you guys uh your health
how how is your health both of you
my wisdom tooth is kicking a little bit
uh but other than that how did that work
bro so first question i had is actually
for angel before we get some people on
um bro being in where you are right
for
however long you're at uh you've been
there for so far
what is one thing you actually don't
like bro if any you know because i know
you talked about a lot of things that
you do like but is there anything that
you don't really like do you miss back
home or is there anything that you're
not really fond of
i miss
having connections with people
is very lonely out here very isolating
but it's a it's a lonely road isn't it
it is man it is
but uh
honestly that's a good and bad thing if
you look about it we got abdul rahman on
on the stream so i'm gonna add him right
now but it's a good thing because oh
sorry it's a bad thing because first and
foremost what you said predominantly
that you feel like you might not have
people and it gets a little lonely but
it's a good thing so
you could give and create and give dawah
and and do more to you know because i
heard the saying that in the west
there's there's uh there's muslims but
no islam
but then in the east and places like
where yeah there's
this islam there's opportunity for islam
um but there's no muslims
you know
or maybe i push it and got it but you
know what i'm trying to say you know
there's no proper muslims there's no
guidance so it could be an opportunity
bro
well there's muslims it's just
it's weird
though
because the language the language
barrier as well
um but it is what it is
it is what it is then
[Music]
yeah but i think you have screen lock
rotation on
oh do i fix this yeah just if you have
auto rotate and then just
inshallah we'll go
okay
okay i'm the labra there we go
how are you guys
i'm dead bro i'm the luck but how are
you good
i'm very good how are you
i'm great i'm great
i'm uh a little bit nervous to be honest
don't worry nothing to be nervous about
man
where are you from bro
it's definitely daylight outside
i'm from uh
i'm from the netherlands and um
currently i'm in the same country as you
and girl i'm in in thailand
mashallah are you the uh the brother
that reached out
yes yeah that's me
brother i've been i've been mean
and then you got a brother bro in
thailand now mashallah
you you're currently still when
empire
i am in
uh
phuket
phuket
so actually i'm now in the in the
southern areas
we have a lot of muslims here
most most provinces like yala patani
they have like 90 muslims actually
so
i arrived in thailand like like five
months ago
so is it okay for me to to tell a story
or
whatever of course yeah of course but
also let us know what brought you here
man
so
what we brought here actually is that um
before
i was living in my country holland
you know i i had everything but
i had a car i had a job i had money i
had friends and family i i'm healthy
but i was never
like 100 happy with my life you know i
always felt that something is missing
so
at some point i decided that after a
period of depression and not feeling so
good like there has to
there has to be some change that's
something has to be
to be changed
i was in in thailand before actually two
years ago with my my family
the moment i got here i was really in
love with the country you know the
people
the food
the weather
it's an amazing country so i decided to
go backpacking actually on my own
so i arrived here last last august
and in the beginning i was also in
phuket um
just stupid things you know haram
partying
a lot of alcohol drugs women you know
the
standard things that unbelievers do
and after a while
i was traveling some more to other
places and i arrived in
in chiang mai
and at this place i my two brothers from
palestine
so we start talking this was funny story
actually it was in uh
in a buddhist temple where i met these
two guys
so we started talking about uh israel
palestine the situation there because of
course i heard about
i heard about this on the news before
and
but i never understood what's like
really happening in the country there so
they they told me like what's happening
there and
after this we'd start talking about
islam
and the more i
i asked them the more i understand like
all the questions i asked they had an
answer on it then
so i started researching myself like
like literally all the questions i had
you might think your audio is uh acting
up and then i can send a message
acing up bro
sorry
in a few moments bro
all right
you can continue going by on me let me
just
go inside here maybe the connection is
better inside
yeah so
i just want to say what i like
to bring to the super chat
so yeah after a while i decided
that um
i want to become a muslim because i was
so afraid you know of dying as a
non-believer because i know of course
what happened if you die a non-believer
so i ate the shahada even before i am
alhamdulillah before i read the quran
and then some of my muslim brothers from
from holland they
they sent the quran for me the
translation so now
i'm reading the quran alhamdulillah
so i'm really thinking now like how can
i help
other people with my story you know i
don't want to talk about myself like
look how good i am i became muslim no i
want to
to bring something for people to learn
from so
inshallah bro first first question bro
that i have for you and
it's a genuine question from me to you
so forget all the viewers all right what
made you
as a man who
lived his own life
thought he had it all figured out
what made you
look at this whole different way of life
this whole different thing because now
you got to learn all these things right
so initially it was like i have to learn
uh muslims pray it might seem daunting
right to a lot of people let's be honest
so what made you despite all of this
still
come into it still give it a shot still
make that decision right because it is a
decision it's not something that anyone
forced you right we don't do that but
what made you still go through with it
bro and just stick with it
uh what made me make this decision
you know
mostly that i i really feel like i need
it
i need islam in my life
to
[Music]
be more peaceful
to have more more more peace in my heart
and to
live a meaningful life you know because
before i didn't
i didn't really know what i want my life
i
didn't know if i wanted to
work again go back to school or
like what's the purpose of life you know
why are we here why what
what what is the the reason that we born
into this life so
islam gives me a reason to live and to
a goal a goal of life to go for it you
know my biggest goal at the moment is
that you know the first thing
the first thing that i i realized when i
became muslim i found the truth is that
but i don't want to keep this for myself
you know i want to share everybody i
want to know the world i was
i had this feeling of like i want to
i want to tell my family i want to i
want to tell my friends so my biggest
goal at this moment is to
get the knowledge get the knowledge
right and
ah
there we go i don't know maybe you're
like covering the micro
no i get a call from somebody and he's
calling me all the time and when he
when he calls me i think you can't hear
me
okay
so sorry man sorry so the thing that i
was saying is that um
the first reaction of me finding out
about the truth is that i don't want to
keep this for myself of course i want to
share this with the world i want to
share it with my my family and my
friends
um
so first of course i have to get the
knowledge right so i'm going back to
school here in thailand they have a
islamic university
i'm gonna inshallah learn arabic and
learn more about the quran and sunnah
so this is like now my biggest goal in
life to
help my friends my family or even
strangers to find out about islam
and to
get as much people as possible on the
straight path
any questions you got uh when are you
starting the school
sorry sorry when are you starting at the
university
so i'm starting in june next semester
inshallah
nice nice night so it's like the spring
semester are you starting in
masha'allah
islamic university in thailand some
people are surprised to hear that
yeah so this is just one islamic
university so the history about the
south is that this used to be an own
kingdom
uh called the kingdom of patani
i'm not sure when thailand like uh
got into this i think it's a while ago
that they conquered this land but the
people still feel like
they want the land back and you know
most of the people here are muslims
so
it's also it doesn't really feel like
being in thailand it's it's feeling like
i've been in another country
since i'm here
and
yeah they get a big university actually
it's also funded i think by saudi arabia
with a lot of muslims and they teach
arabic we also have a lot of uh
teachers from arab countries from egypt
from
uh many other places mauritius many
other places and
the schools is
the people are very
on the deen you know they are very uh
religious and practicing islam
so
for me i also feel like i need to go
here to get away from my country with
all the haram with all the
the bad influences to
live in another environment
um
at this moment i think this is the the
best for me and i would also suggest to
other people that feel like the
environment is not like
really supporting islam and you feel
like this is like hard on you that
go travel and maybe you'll find another
place that that's better for you and
easier for you to practice islam
yeah you know you remind me of an ayah
in the quran
he mentions that he made the earth vast
and i don't know the full hadith so i'm
not going to or sorry i don't know the
full ayah so i'm not going to really
quote it but a lot of scholars mentioned
that if if you live in a place that
is kind of prohibiting you from
practicing islam then allah made the
earth vast and you can move and you
should move out to other places but and
i guess living in the west isn't really
for everyone or living in certain
countries isn't for everyone but there
are those that
uh
have the goal of going there and
spreading dawah there inshallah and i
think that's actually something that's
lacking and you know to some degree in
certain places in the world
um
especially like you know the west so
alhamdulillah i think what you're doing
is great have even
lots and lots of barakah in it and
elevate you and bless you and make you a
you know
uh
an amazing student of knowledge
insha'allah i mean i mean i mean
i mean bro it was it was a pleasure
speaking with you bro unfortunately
anna's still not here um and we'll get
the next person on
zach laker bro i'm gonna make dua that
allah keeps you steadfast on the deen
bro just understand that
it is you know allah says in the quran
that do they think they'll they'll say
that they believe and they won't be
tested right so i know you know that you
know being muslim it has its own trials
and tribulations right um but understand
too that one of the biggest trials and
tribulations is just becoming muslim
right so the fact that you already did
that commend yourself for that you know
don't be too hard on yourself don't put
too much pressure on yourself put enough
pressure but understand that you you did
something that most people wouldn't do
bro which is the most challenging thing
and they actually let their ego down and
they did the most logical rational and
truthful thing which is to accept islam
and now it's a matter of just
taking the time alhamdulillah to just
learn a little bit more every day become
one percent better every day and may
allah i mean
thank you but the other thing i want to
say is that i didn't choose to be a
muslim
of course at the end i choose myself but
allah invited me and
it's only by the qatar of allah that
became muslim that before i was
traveling i didn't
i never thought about becoming a muslim
of course it just it just happened to me
you know
subhanallah bro
hi bro
salaam alaikum thank you so much for
having me and uh
all right
all right so
next person
i feel like bro loki just uh storing
this uh this link
and letting like
yeah bro honestly man but
unfortunately for now it's still gonna
be members only for a few minutes we'll
see you from there
let's see
oh
and get over here bro
let's do it baby
it's been a week since uh you know every
every monday with aunt west fitness bibi
how's everyone doing man we got 113
viewers let us know how are your days
your nights your evenings your
afternoons how are they going
um
you know
i was just about to ask bro kawami i was
gonna ask without the same brother
masha'allah of course may allah bless
you i'm saying it was my honor
bro
welcome bro welcome to the
welcome to the best side of life bro
honestly i hate i sound biased bro to a
lot of non-muslims bro but it is what it
is bro
it's it's truly the best one of the best
decisions you'll make in life bro
100
wait kwame bro why don't you come up
here why don't you um
join us
kwame you can join us you don't have to
feel pressured to join us in video you
can even join us in audio that would be
fine too just
it'll be very beneficial inshaallah
and wes bro let's go
talk is cheap bro let's go
my gosh it's so nice to be on this show
i like you guys all the time
what brings you what brings you over
tonight
well i saw i'm i'm a patreon member so i
saw that you were having one so i
actually wanted to be on and just ask
you guys like how was the process
because i also want to do my own
like i want to do some with my muslim
sisters we do a halica and we also want
to start a youtube channel so i just
wanted to ask about your journey sorry i
just got in so i don't know if there's
any topics or anything i don't know if
my question was random
no worries no worries today we had this
informal topic that was just going to be
mainly for uh reverts but not at all we
don't have anyone in the world
so we'll answer your question too and if
you feel comfortable you can share your
story too okay
thank you
all right so around me bro how would you
tackle this all right well first and
foremost may allah bless your sister and
and the sisters that you know are
involved in the project or the projects
in soon to be
i mean i think that it's great that
their sisters getting involved in it to
have a sister's helicopter a sister's
channel and maybe the sisters equivalent
to tetherium i think would be phenomenal
insha allah because us as a man bro you
know we're going to understand you know
men more than women so to be absolutely
fair i think there should be sisters in
sha allah giving dawah aside from that
about the journey specifically i think
we each have our own experience that you
know overlaps in some places but it's
going to be unique to each other so for
me i would say personally
first and foremost make the sincere
intention for the sake of allah
put your heart and your soul into it but
don't set expectations for yourself
right don't set the expectation that
you're gonna hit you know 50 000
subscribers in a year or anything like
that do it purely for the sake of allah
have a wise plan
in what you create how you create it how
you talk how you speak you know you'll
utilize the real skills you need to have
a podcast
um and just network as much as possible
that's basically i think what we did
a year plus later
we're here
okay thank you
sisters t3m inshallah
says if you wouldn't mind giving us uh
you know now that we have you
i want to use this opportunity if you
feel comfortable to tell us a little bit
about your story you don't need to go
into any details that you don't want to
get into
but you know tell us about your your
islam bro your dean your journey let us
know
okay yes so um my parents so my mother
was a 7-day adventist christian
and my father he wasn't really anything
but some of his family members were
muslims so i was exposed to islam when i
was younger through his brothers and
sisters um and i would share time with
sometimes i'd stay with my mom sometimes
i stay with my dad but mostly my dad
um when i was 15 years old i was really
you know trying to find god because i
used to go to church with my mom but i
didn't really feel that place
you know i would ask a lot of questions
and get in trouble
especially when it came to you know
jesus dying for our sins and a lot of
other things like that those questions
it just didn't sit right with me just
knowing like god would kill somebody
innocent for us i would ask those type
of questions or even like um because
we're seven-day adventists we have
certain modesty guidelines that we had
to follow but if i went to another
church i was like why didn't they cover
their head or how come some christians
eat pork and others don't like for
seven-day adventists you know we had
dietary restrictions that we found we
couldn't eat pork or shellfish but if i
would go other places or my other
friends you know they would practice
their christianity so differently to the
point it would make me feel like i don't
understand and nobody was really
answering my question so when i was 15 i
asked my uncle and he actually gave me a
quote so that was the first time that i
read the quran and it resonated with me
and when i got to college alhamdulillah
took my shahada and i decided to become
muslim and it wasn't really you know
easy because my mom's side of the family
really wasn't for it they weren't happy
about it
um
but
i just kept praying and making dua
and
yeah that's that's basically my story i
from getting the quran when i was 15 it
really helped me take that journey to
accept islam into my heart
so i'm doing i'm happy that allah used
my uncle and my aunts to introduce me to
it and
guide me
mashallah what is one thing aside from
you know being
being muslim that one thing that you're
truly grateful for now after islam
what i'm truly grateful for um
that's hard there's so many things i'm
grateful for i'm definitely
grateful for modesty
that was a hard
journey for me especially because my
parents are from the caribbean and i
don't know if you know about caribbean
culture carnival things of that nature
but modesty is definitely um
something that's only done in church or
only done in a spiritual setting all the
rest of the day is very dressing in a
provocative manner is the norm and it's
basically expected you know it's taught
at a young age you know that's what
women or or ladies are supposed to do
but in actuality um
it very much took a
horrible toll on my mental health and my
self-esteem because i realized that
you know
being taught or pushed that your body or
you dressing a certain way is the only
way people will value you um is not
something good that young women should
should be taught or grow up under so i'm
definitely thankful for modesty um
definitely when i took my shahada i wore
the hijab right away that was so easy
for me it actually felt freeing because
i felt like okay i don't have to conform
anymore i don't have to
be or meet everybody's expectations now
i can just
i felt free and like i really did feel
free to cover myself and i take and
looking back i did not you know
appreciate it when my uncle would
express it to me hey you know i'm not
trying to force anything on you but you
should dress more modestly i didn't
really appreciate it and now looking
back on it i that's number one
appreciate and toheed you know the
oneness of god because that's what i was
searching for i was just like this
doesn't make sense to me and so now
having the unity of god in islam i had
so much peace because before i was so
confused
and it's now it's like now it's not
confusing anymore i know i don't worship
a man
that i don't worship a trinity with just
one god so those two things tahit and
modesty i definitely appreciate it allah
says allah mubarak may allah continue to
bless you and your uncle uh to the
utmost degree i mean and it's great that
you you looked at it as in it's freeing
you know and i understand i can't
understand the female struggle because
you know to me it's just like oh just
cover up you know but for women it's
different right
it's the whole feeling like you're not
fitting in it's the whole pressure it's
a whole societal expectation so i'm not
gonna front and act like i know what you
know y'all go through on a day-to-day
basis but the fact that you know you
said it it's a living testament that it
can be done and it is something that it
is a choice right no one can force it
but
it is a choice that that you took and
alhamdulillah that you're grateful for
yeah because it takes like i i don't
know how to explain it but i don't know
if you ever
you guys did you guys grew up in new
york i don't know
if you
[Music]
i grew up in like florida and puerto
rico and puerto rico well especially
here i grew my parents they came to this
country and i was born here in new york
so just going to high school it was just
the everyday pressure of you know if i
dress too boyish i'll be criticized not
wearing enough makeup criticism
especially from your own family members
i think that's what really takes a toll
on you especially for women when you
don't get that love and support from
your family to be like no you're okay
how you are you don't need makeup you
don't need this so i think that's why as
for women especially new reverts or even
women who might have been born muslim
modesty is such an issue because all day
in the media where we're bombarded with
the beautiful woman looks like this or
looks a certain way or men or even women
downgrading you because you're not
dressing appealing enough oh my gosh
you're wearing that that's too baggy
because even now like even though i i've
been i'm 22 now so i've been muslim for
a while i i still even when i go to
certain masters i can hear the little
gossiping and chatter about certain
things where you know i'm just here like
oh my gosh we we're supposed to be
muslim so those type of things shouldn't
matter to us
but we have to remember we uh we live in
america we live in a western world so
those things will still affect us and
it's going to be a trial but
alhamdulillah will persevere as long as
we make sure that we remember that allah
comes first and we're not doing this for
a wildly gain we're doing this for the
hereafter
and say this one last thing because i
think we're going to allah
soon but
this is exactly why we need a podcast
because everything you just said is the
narrative that like you know
you know sisters don't talk sisters and
there's a standard in the eyes of woman
and the eyes of men there's this like
business entire industry on
beautification of women and everything
uh and all of this stuff is
for a lot better term on islamic and
this is why we need this podcast so if
you are able to learn the skills to be
able to articulate that in a way where
you impact the majority of people that
hear it or everyone who hears it then
that is something in sha allah that i
think i truly believe will go the
distance
inshallah assistant i just wanted to say
one thing quickly because you know we do
have a lot of people in the waiting room
that when you do get your channel sorted
out and you got the platform in sha
allah we'd love to do a collab with you
and uh it will be your utmost honor
insha allah thank you thank you so much
for having me thank you
just reach out to us on patreon when
you've got everything sorted out yes
[Music]
glad to see you all man i just wanna um
just say um you know um
for all the work that you're doing for
the ummah and may allah you know
increase you guys in knowledge and in
success in what you're doing inshallah i
mean i
mean um
brothers i just have a suggestion what
two suggestions for people that i would
love to see on your podcast and these
two people have expressed interest um on
coming on to to your show uh one of them
being hamza's den um
brother hamza from hamza's then i'm not
sure if you've heard it comes of mine
right yeah yeah yeah
yeah
around me bro you you kind of echo do
you mind repeating yourself oh yeah
sorry i said i can reach out to him
afterwards inshallah i didn't know he he
spoke about wanting to come on
yeah yeah he's that he mentioned it um i
think on the live show i think i asked
him would you like to do a free muslims
um
like an appearance on the show and he
goes yeah i would love to but the
brothers haven't contacted me i thought
okay
and now i feel ashamed shall i
definitely reach out to him inshallah
and also um that the second person i'm
not sure if you've heard of her her
name's liz edwards she reacts to a lot
of islamic
uh content and she seems very close to
the dean um
inshallah and i was wondering if you
guys could reach out to her and she's
also expressed interest in coming on
your show and speaking to you guys
yeah insha'allah bro do you have one do
you have our instagram by any chance um
i'm not sure if i i'm not sure exactly
what it is but if he was to go onto her
youtube channel liz edwards there's a
link there um i was a patreon and and i
did ask her and she really did want to
come on to the show so
that's
um
this isn't the first time speaking bro
give us more fruitful conversations
uh if not in this life than the next may
allah continue putting baraka bro thanks
for the suggestions and until next time
welcome
hi bro at west fitness bb i know you're
here bro no you're in the waiting room
bro i want to take my time with you bro
so i'm just going to quickly get out
this one person in the waiting room too
and insha allah
can you guys hear me
difficult to
use sorry i'm having some mic issues
all right no worries just gonna put you
real quick in the waiting room while you
sort that out inshallah
and
we can get the technical difficulties
aside
all right man the man the myth the
legend
the people that
bro the people's person bro the one that
everyone's been waiting for
aunt westminster what to do bro
what's good y'all how y'all doing
bro doing good how about you
i'm all right i'm all right
listen bro let's cut right into it man
we we teased them long enough last
episode all right last week
let's go into it man let's go into it we
love we'd love to you know get you on a
separate episode obviously but you know
assuming you know we got the time now
let's go in man tell us tell us a little
bit deeper into your story bro stuff
that we didn't cover last time
oh man it's uh so i mean i i guess we
could start i'm gonna try to like break
it down but i guess we could start from
the beginning um
so when i was just a kid man like it was
just uh there was like a natural feeling
um with me growing up like when i was
like i was very very young at a very
young age like i probably about like
five four six years old
i instinctively just felt in my heart
and like just in general like this
feeling of like there's something more
than me
and it loves me and cares for me
and uh you know as time goes on like i
used to be very avid as far as like
learning about the more spiritual side
of things
uh so
there was just times where you know for
example my father wasn't around uh you
know i was raised by women my entire
life
uh there was just a lot of different
things that i personally questioned
so
one of the things i used to question
what's my spiritual side um because you
know when you go down this walk of life
there's so many experiences that you get
like whether it be from just you know
happy memories or bad memories it was
always something that
i had to think about like it was like
what is this like why am i going through
all these things like as far especially
the bad things because i felt like i had
way more bad memories than good ones
but
every single time that i had like for
example
uh a bad experience i always felt like i
came out the end of that pretty
well unscathed
and i say that you know in the spiritual
sense like some people will allow these
negative things to go through to affect
their uh perspective of life and just
continue to live
that way and for me like you know there
would be people for example not to say
like you know i try to put myself in a
pedestal per se but in general there
will be people that um that went through
terrible things
and because i always try to keep a
positive spirit
they'll always be like you're such an
amazing person like there's lighting you
all these other things and i used to
like you know i used to say like yeah
you know
i just try to remain positive because
there's so many people that just allow
these negative things to affect their
perspective and their uh way of life
but as time went on um i think the
biggest thing that happened for me was
when i lost my best friend
uh he had committed suicide when uh in
2017
and i at the time
you know i just came out of trade school
at the time
was you know just really hurt like i was
just like man like and you know the
thing he was an atheist i'm not afraid
to say he always had a lot of questions
he always liked to argue about things
uh bring his opinion up but like it just
felt like he was uh spiritually empty
like he had nothing
to really give himself in life
so
uh after he passed you know there was
just something in me saying go live for
him a little bit
and uh granted some people to see that
subjectively um as far as like you
should you shouldn't do that but i
wanted to live life for him per se
uh so i went and uh decided to say you
know what i'm gonna get in contact with
my dad's side of the family uh my great
great aunt on that side she's very
successful woman like she makes like
over a hundred thousand a year
um she worked overseas in japan and then
worked in italy um she actually uh gave
me bought me a ticket to go out there
and said like as long as you get your
passport you can come out to pay for
your ticket to come out here we can have
a conversation
so
i flew out there and she just told me
like you know this is what you need to
do
and one of the things that she
definitely recommended that i do first
of all was you know once again kind of
crazy
explore the spiritual side of myself
first and like question what i believe
in first because like you don't have
like a foundation of what you believe in
everything else kind of falls on the
wayside like it just has no foundation
so
uh you know that was kind of hard for me
though because you know my friend had
passed away and i was just like man like
i didn't know how to take that so for a
long time even after trade school when i
decided to walk with god again i came to
back to a kind of like place where i was
just
just spiritual i didn't really follow
anything go by any guidelines i mean i
meditated
um
i did a lot of different things i
explored different religions but nothing
really clicked
for me per se as if anything the only
thing that really clicked for me was you
know
you know the abrahamic religions because
they were the closest to me growing up
uh but essentially uh after that i had
reached out to a few brothers of mine
and one of the guys that i worked with
was a muslim uh muslim fellow his name
is uh muhammad and he was just like
reaching out to me he was just like hey
man like hopefully you're doing all
right uh i saw that your friend passed
away you know he was really kind and
things of that nature and you know a lot
of other friends reached out too
but
i think the biggest thing what this is
what i'm about to actually put in my one
of my videos soon
um
i was drinking a lot
so i had one out with one of my friends
and he was he's a really we're still
friends he's a really good guy
uh granted he has like some like like
lifestyle things that he decides to do
when i don't partake it anymore but
he was like say come out let's have a
drink and all these other things i'll go
drinking like every single weekend even
if i was broke i would still go drink
and i was like i shouldn't do this i
shouldn't do this but i still did it
anyway
and
over time i just noticed a trend because
he actually moved to denver colorado and
i stayed where i'm at and here in
richmond
so
it was just really hard as far as like
you know like him being gone and then my
friend was you know my friend had still
passed away so i have like other friends
but like they're always busy with their
lives and
careers and jobs
and
i just noticed a trend with myself i was
drinking every single weekend and it was
one time i almost passed out like black
trunk
and it was just at that point where i
was just like
i'm just done uh i'm like i'm just
cutting this out and i decided to like
just part ways with that
um and you know that was something in my
mind
when i was like having a conversation
with this muslim girl that i knew now
granted uh we were friends like for like
a long time like we've had like an on
and off relationship it's just as far as
like speaking to each other because she
like really is like her family's like
really really
embedded into the religion like they
don't really
even with texting she they don't even
like it you know so i was just like okay
wow that's crazy but
but uh nonetheless uh she was like we
were having a conversation about uh
alcohol drinking and at the course at
this time i was like taking a long break
it was almost about like at five months
i had not drinking anything
and uh she was just like yeah like you
know you know it's a sin in our religion
to drink
and i was like
it's a sin
you know like even in christianity it's
a it's it's not necessarily a sin to
drink but it's a sin to get drunk like
it's not the same kind of concept but
it was like to me just in general
drinking was a sin
and i was like i used to i was like
really trying to like say to myself i
don't think there's anything wrong with
it as long as you do it in moderation
like some things in moderation is okay
but you know we had a little bit of an
argument about that
and then uh
honestly it was at that point where i
was kind of thinking to myself like i
was being like somebody's you know uh
what's his name david wood i was kind of
being like these guys
and like uh was really just like man
they like this religion is crazy like
they like they do too much but then i
was like thinking to myself like about
my best friend that passed and he was
very open-minded granted he did not
agree and i believe in certain things
but he one thing for sure is that he
always kept an open mind so i was like
man like what's happened to me i become
very close-minded so i said you know
what
let me dive into this i'm gonna let me
just see if i could dive into this and
if i find any questions i'm gonna just
you know find anything that i don't like
then i'm gonna ask questions about it
and i'm gonna be and then it was like
times where i was like and i actually
the funny thing is when the first person
that i
i ran across when i started discovering
islam unfortunately was david wood i
watched this whole video about like
if i if i if you prove me wrong i'll
convert i watch the whole video and i
was like oh man it's like yo like this
man is going in you know for no reason
and i was like hold up like let me just
watch other videos
so
to my surprise i started discovering
mufty mink uh
you know sheikh with my farouk was one
of my other people i went to for the web
message foundation
i watched all of his videos
every single one like not every single
one but i watched a good majority i mean
this was for like five months like i did
this
and bro
not to interrupt you because you're on a
roll right now but three things one you
said david wood got no reason he does
have a reason bro he's getting those
benjamins bro
he's getting a lot of that patreon money
bro speaking speaking just idiotic
things that he's doing number two sheikh
with man farooq bless him i saw your
video with him on the one message
foundation channel bro
so good work bro good work and number
three
we're doing a live stream with sheikh
with money and furu this friday i'm
gonna say it again 7 p.m eastern
standard time same time bro you know you
got to tune in for that but carry on bro
oh man i'm definitely tuning in for that
you know i love that guy man love that
guy um but yeah like i just uh you know
i i promise you like i was i told him i
even said it in the video but
essentially
i would literally i promise you i would
just sit there i'll be in my in like in
my room just chilling and i will just
watch a video all right i'm like i got
this question and see if he answers it
answer the question whether he be
debating someone or arguing with someone
regardless of what it was he would
answer the question i'm like all right
and it'll be another video and i'll be
like i'm going to watch this too
i promise you if i had like another
question it would be the next video i'll
watch it would be like answer my
question
and i'm like i'm like yo what
and it was literally like getting to a
point where i had nothing i really like
had no other questions like i had
nothing
really left to you know ask because you
know i wanted to for the one thing is
that you know like i said before as far
as me being young and having that
feeling i didn't know i think it's if i
correct me if i'm wrong it's called the
frick or thicker or something like that
that was like something that kind of
sparked me the most and it was just like
i believe that like i truly do believe
that because that's what i felt when i
was young like i felt that
internal feeling like i was close to
something higher than me
and all i wanted to do was fulfill that
so you know that was just one of the
biggest things and i think like i
discovered you guys because of angel
because you know once again i've been
watching him for a long time i watched
this video and the thing is like it was
kind of surprising to my uh
surprising to me because like i hadn't
watched him in probably about like four
or five months
and i come back and i just see that he
has a video saying that he's
he was going to islam and i was like
whoa you know what i mean like it's been
like a while like i've seen his videos
so and i saw that and it was like yo
that that spoke levels to me now i'm
going to give you guys something
i was going to put this in here but i
want to i'm going to be real with you
guys because you guys are dope i like
your content
and uh you guys are amazing
but this is one last little piece that
kind of made me think like okay
you know i mean let me just do this
so i was actually like you know very
close to saying you know what let me go
to a masjid nearby and let me convert
like right now
but i was like ah you know kind of like
one of those people when they're like
okay let me quit something let me do
this one more time
and then i'll quit it and go cold turkey
for good
so i hit up all my side pieces
all of them every single one
and i promise you like and it was like
the you know you guys know you guys are
guys you understand but
i had like all of them that i went to
every single one about five of them
either blocked me for some weird reason
because they were like i promise and i
even reached out to them texted them too
and i was like why you block me
i'm not about that life anymore
you know something like that
the muslim girl that i told you about
she had you know she decided to cut ways
because she was like i'm trying to find
a muslim man that's actually more
in tune uh with him you know with uh
with his spirituality and i understand
you're brand new to this or you're about
to be but i think i want something else
third girl she found a man and then the
fourth girl i think like she had like
decided to delete all of her social
media just kind of go off the record
and the fifth one she actually was like
also she found a man
and at this point it was kind of like
it felt like you know
i might be crazy but it just felt like
god or allah was just stripping all of
this stuff from my life even terrible
friends that blocked me and like removed
me from my life
and i was just like
you know what
let me just go into it so you're not
even fighting it bro it's like there's a
level of understanding the fitna or the
trials and tests and tribulations that
we got our way it's another level
knowing that allah has your back and
allah is literally putting a barricade
bro and how foolish are we to take that
barricade down ourselves bro but we do
it left right and center bro we do this
every day we do this week by week
we're unintentionally doing it but
sometimes we're intentionally we know
better but we shouldn't be doing it bro
and and that barricade that a lot puts
for us
it really should be something that we
shouldn't really play around with bro
because who knows if the last time you
take it down is the last time that you
get to take it down
100 100
and i think like there's just a you know
a man trust me and when i say
there's multiple more examples but like
the it's just kind of crazy to me you
know like because it even when i think
back in other parts of my life
it would be like i try to
i always try to like kind of do exactly
what you said like it's almost like the
people that weren't really meant for me
or like just
not meant to be in my life period it
just felt like even though i wanted to
stay connected to them in some way shape
or form whether it be friendship or more
it just felt like something was always
trying to pull it away from me or like
just they were just like you know
because i promise you it wouldn't be
like oh they decided that we had an
argument we decided to part ways it'd be
like no
like something in them had sparked in
them and said i don't want to do this
anymore like i don't yeah you know it
was fun while it lasted or this was cool
but you know i don't want to you know i
want to get away from that and i was
like wow like you know it just felt like
that my entire life so that was just
something another reason to say
you know let me just
look
yeah and it's great because you know you
got some brothers here now inshallah and
um i mean i don't know if i should like
kind of spoil the news
brother here he actually joined my class
um at the i3 institute so he has many
many more brothers alhamdulillah and
he's insha allah
i think it's amazing i think it's great
on that on a week to week basis you know
we get to meet up and learn
and share our thoughts and everything so
i'm honored honestly to have you in that
class habibi i look forward to seeing
you uh this wednesday insha'allah 7-9
that's just my final words before we uh
bring i think the sister back which
fellowship robotic bro yeah i just want
to quickly tell you personal uh from me
to you bro go to our channel if you
haven't seen this already watch episode
93 that we dropped that's 9-3
i think you'd particularly find this
uh insightful bro it was with a
celebrity mma trainer feral zahabi i
don't know if you know
but when he's not out here doing the the
wonderful things he's doing he's also
a philosopher by night and i think this
was a very nice insightful conversation
may allah allow you to you know benefit
from this bro in just one way shape or
form and
world mutual is now on instagram right
so i'll send you i'll dm you another
video i'd rather not say this you know
in public but i'll send you that and uh
i think anna knows what i'm talking
about i think you'll find that
beneficial too inshallah until next time
bro assalamu alaikum
malika masalam thank you for having me
y'all guys take it easy
all
right
hey thanks for bringing that guys
worries no worries could you hear as
well
yeah can you hear me tim
yeah
what's on your mind
cool so i just tuned in but is this just
everyone telling reaver stories
more or less river toys or if you
uh you know born muslims that were not
on deen and now they're on theme they're
welcome too
okay cool because that's kind of my
story so um
i actually like i was
in quran classes like learning to
memorize since i was maybe three or four
and i don't know if you guys can relate
to this fire to rami but
i always had this feeling of like
i i think it was my fit that i never
felt like allah wasn't real or had the
sense of denying him but i'm more so
because
school was so focused just on rote
memorization like i never built that
connection with allah i never really
understood
what islam was to its core so that was
very much just like that was my
weekend's life like i would go back to
school and like
almost feel
almost feel ashamed of just being
different from people like i wouldn't
want to tell people that my family was
muslim i wouldn't tell people what i was
doing on the weekends all that kind of
stuff um
and all that started to change when i
went to college because
you know being away from home like i
felt i finally got this opportunity to
do everything that i you know thought i
wanted to do to be the person that i
thought i wanted to be and
that was fun for a good like three
months maybe
but
it very quickly got to a point of like
okay like
now what you know
and um
i kept having like experiences that
would just bring me back to
to thinking about allah to
considering that this was
the most
like the realest thing in my life
and one day i just had this thought of
like
what
what will happen if i just do
actually practice what will happen if i
just do submit
and
that
moment and that day changed my life
forever because
i remember like specifically it was
november morning and i walked outside
after praying fajr and like the snow on
the ground was like sparkling in a way
i'd never seen before and i was just
like literally seeing the whole world so
differently it was crazy and i just i
i had this knowing
in my heart and in my soul and my whole
body that just that
what i'd come upon was real and true and
ever since then
i've
not only believed in allah but i
i can feel him in my life i can
have a certain sense of
obviously i don't know that it's 100
accurate but
very often i have a sense of when he
wants something for me or doesn't want
something for me
and again i praise tejada often to eat
that as well because
i'm still just a human but
um like the last brother was saying as
well like oftentimes a lot of people in
my life who
i thought were good for me but in
reality were bringing me away from islam
and farther from allah he took them out
of my life and
i went through a lot of things that i
thought
were
that i thought were bad that ended up
being blessings because they brought me
closer and closer to allah and um
actually i have a question for you guys
because
now i'm at this point where like like i
said um
back i guess
um i'm kind of at this point where i'm
so like
so deeply wanting to just immerse myself
in my practice
that
i don't really feel like i resonate with
any of my old friends anymore because
none of them are muslim
and
especially like being a muslim woman
i live in new york so it's probably
easier than in most other places but i
guess i just don't know
where and how to connect to other muslim
women and make more muslim friends so i
wonder if you guys have any
recommendations for that
well on my own first and foremost on a
lot first i want to say that i um
in terms of you know really starting to
practice islam
for me it was more so like i literally
came across a video on youtube and then
from there on out i recognized that this
is the truth and
i just kind of i started educating
myself and you know practicing from
there but i did have many
not like now i think about many many
events beforehand where it's like
i'm going to use this as an analogy
right this is not what happened but it
kind of makes the point
really obvious that
i was in a situation where like you know
the alcohol
bottle is like to my lips but like it
just the alcohol would not pour in my
mouth that's like the best analogy i can
give for situations i've been in before
where i was literally close to doing
something like i would say tragic you
know for me my myself my nufs
and it just did not happen it's it
reminds me of the prophet
because i remember i don't know if this
is authentic or not right so i'll take
it with a grain of salt but i remember
hearing the story of the process when he
was younger he tried to go to like an
adventure like i guess you can call it
like a celebration or party that quraish
kind of they they celebrated or whatever
and it's narrated and again i don't know
if it's authentic but it says that allah
kind of struck the ears of the prophet
saw i said and he like he would he
passed out so he would try and go and he
would kind of pass out or fall asleep
before he can actually get there and
that's like allah protecting him from
the fitnah and stuff that would go on at
these uh events and again third time i
want to be very clear i don't know if
it's authentic
but i i remember hearing that i just
want to kind of use that as an analogy
but in terms of friends i think
alhamdulillah
it's beautiful and it's amazing that you
realize you don't resonate with them and
that's basically your akida versus their
okay that you have beliefs that they
don't have
and when you don't resonate on that
level with people you know you
subconsciously just want to get away
from them until it becomes conscious
that you know you have to get away from
them
so in terms of finding friends firstly i
want to recommend that you join the i3
institute the letter i the number three
institute
i would recommend this to uh
i recommend every single person who go
there because uh
you will find brothers or not brothers
but you will find out for me brothers
but you'll find sisters there in
insha'allah
um and you will actually you know be
able to learn islam
uh i would say in a really proper sense
while you're there um but in terms of
your local area i would go to the
masajid and i think all you need is one
or two good muslim sisters and then from
there they could recommend their sisters
and you can kind of expand that group
that's exactly what happened with me i
found one brother introduced me to other
brothers and this this kind of
multiplied over time than that i got you
bro i got you
so
that was a joke
oh my
god draw me man you gotta be quicker man
but uh
i i think that uh
that's the the best way to go about it
just not work it do it for the sake of
allah
actually i tried to join i3 but they
haven't responded to me since i joined
when was that
it was like a week ago for your
recommendation live inshallah you can
join my class so just a message t3 i'm
on instagram inshaallah and then i'll
have you join the class oh cool thanks
and the advice i'm going to give is
nothing too different for me but what i
do want to say is how i met rami
all right so picture this all right
you're in the most
sweaty gym
that it's like it's literally like
steaming bro it's literally the most
budget type of gym right
you're not going there for dawah no one
else is going there for dawa you go in
just trying to get some sets and reps
and get that pump before you go outside
and do your thing
and i see this guy right as i'm as i'm
getting my tricep sets in
and he comes up to me and he's like
yo uh could you show me how to do that
and then i was like i was just you know
demonstrating and explaining it
and you know he just kept saying
mashallah alhamdulillah to like
everything i was saying i was like a
part of me was like does he know i'm
muslim but then another part of me was
like is he just the type of person that
just says that anyway and he doesn't
really care if the person's muslim so i
was kind of intrigued right i took his
you know we finished talking i
demonstrated that and then one thing led
to another somehow i believe we
exchanged instagram you know it counts
because he just seemed like a chill guy
rami this was like three four years ago
i think
and yeah and at the end of the i went on
his instagram and he had these very
interesting videos on his instagram like
proving god's existence
i'm saying that because bro the freaking
production quality bro it was not you
know stuff like
the stuff we have now it was literally
just just like you talking to a camera
like these this black screen or whatever
but it was very interesting and i never
thought about these these things
and subhanallah you know we just i think
i messaged him another day and then we
just we bumped them bumped into each
other one more time in the gym
and just look where we are now
subhanallah like allah literally has the
best of of plans just ready for you and
the reason i tell you this sister is
because i was actually struggling with a
group of friends that were not
particularly conducive to me and my
islam
and i unfortunately
well now it's fortunate but i took the
difficult decision to let them go
just the day before that
and i knew it was something that i
shouldn't do and i didn't want to do at
the time but i knew it was the right
thing to do and i put my tawakkal and
trust in allah and i did it and within
24 hours in the sweaty gym i met on me
it's crazy
i wanna i wanna bring kind of my side of
the story there because leading up to
that
you know i think about it and i asked
myself the question what the heck was
that in that gym you know i was never a
person who really strived to work out
stuff i'm then i'm back into it now but
like before that i would like bro
i was a person that i got a gym
membership and i would only go with my
cousin to like kind of spar a little bit
oh with the sister girl
maybe you're like battery that or
something but you can still finish the
story bro for all the viewers yeah so
um i was that kind of person i wouldn't
really hit the gym much so i'm asking
myself why the heck was that there and i
realized a lot i went through a really
really rough patch in life and it was
trying to get married and all that i
talk about it a lot but it really
impacted my life the reason i was in
that gym is because i was basically
heartbroken by a woman and i went to
that phase with you know i was like oh
i'm going to go i'm going to get buffed
she's going to look at me regret you
know losing me and all that flex on her
yeah and i made all these life changes
you know especially like when it comes
to practicing the deen
let's bring her in
so
so basically i was going through a rough
patch and
i decided that you know i wanna
you know learn my dean i wanna be good i
wanna give dawah online and i wanna work
out and become you know more buff but
all of those were my goals and you see
how all of those kind of
uh you know affected the situation
because i'm in the gym i meet the
brother and he checks on my instagram
and i'm making it i'm making an effort
to give dawah on there and everything
all because allah tested me in a way
where i was like i need to improve
myself
and everything you know was history
alhamdulillah it's really beautiful man
she was probably gonna cry man
[Music]
i'm good bro i'm good i just want to you
know
my apologies for you know you being in
this stream in the waiting room this
long
oh so much fun too many people in the
waiting room but finally you're here man
what's poppin
ah not much i was actually eating dinner
that's why i didn't i was like ah give
me a sec
bro do you want to introduce us
yeah it's very well i have a i have a
specialist masha'allah helping me you
know track my calories make a plan and
everything i've actually had two experts
that may or may not be you know in this
panel with me that have helped me with
this and uh you know lo and behold i'm
i'm packing some mighty guns under this
really heavy jacket that you guys know
i'm the love bro aunt west fitness bb
asks or anthony mccomb now
how's the buff thing going
that's that's what romney responded
let's put on me bro okay okay okay got
you
i thought he was just uh something up
but anyway uh tell us a little bit about
brother kwame bro you mentioned that he
reached out to you before
yeah so brother kawami um he's a brother
that um
hit the t3m instagram up hamdina and it
was very beautiful masha'allah he told
me that he's basically been living and i
don't want to give his story about just
what i know he said he's basically been
living a muslim life but he hasn't given
his shahadah
and it was amazing it found a lot of
someone who's a muslim technically that
or a muslim practically because they
practice islam in a way but they haven't
given their shahada
and i was really honestly personally i
was dumbfounded by that i was trying i
was like well that's you know in a way
it's amazing uh and you know for his own
reasons which i'm not going to share
because i don't know if it's you know
it's not up to me to share his stuff
um he hadn't taken the shahada yet and
he wanted to so i said you know
i'll do it inshallah i can do it with
you if you're down let's do it
and for a lack of a better term he was
kind of like nah well on hill bro
i want hill to help me with my shahada
because uh at the time he thought that
angel lived where he lives and i said
you know
angel moved out of the country bro
me is like
like with my mom she didn't later on
she didn't later on convert over until
probably like
uh the
right after my second brother after me
came
so pretty much all
six of them six of my brothers and my
sister
they're all muslim
now me i you know at the time she was
young she had me in high school so i
missed out on that but because of
you know my brothers and my sister my
mom converting over they were already
muslim
now when we attended
uh it was a islamic islamic class um at
the masjid in tucson
i want to say i remember
doing a shahada
i'm not too
sure uh
but i didn't i didn't want to you know
leave this world and then you know i'm
standing in front of my lord and he's
like you know brother
you've been practicing the ways and like
how come you didn't do it you know
that's the last thing i didn't want
so
i was like oh might as well you know do
it again i've already been living it
i've been overseas
and actually you know
got to really experience it which was
really beautiful
um
what was it
then i came what eventually happened
what brought me back because i would
i've been on a
roller coaster with my dean you know i'm
still working on it not perfect but you
know i'm
pushing it hard right now especially
when i moved from
uh back home
arizona and then now i live in north
carolina
and just praying to allah asking him hey
you know
uh
make it better for me get me out of my
situation back home it's i mean it's
it was okay but you know
it could have been better and
he blessed me moved me out here north
carolina and
that's when you know i went
crazy downhill like how you said
i got my abc store drinking every day
and you know i just lost myself for a
little bit and
you know it took me
um
it took me
you know meeting uh my wife
and you know
preaching to her
you know showing her the way and
eventually she took her shahadah
and when she took her shahada it it
pretty much impacted me right there to
just you know what hey i need to quit
man this is like
you know every time i'm doing hot on
it's like you get that that voice in the
back of your head that's telling you
like hey uh
what would what would your lord think
what would he think you know
and it's like sometimes i would you know
listen to it but it's you know it's just
like you said uh if i had uh
uh shaitaan has a way of
beautifying the haram for you
you know um
but other than that she took her shahada
and you know now we're both hitting us
strong you know we're not perfect we're
trying to get back on track uh my goal
right now is you know trying to
take on arabic classes if i can
um inshallah if allah allows me
um
but that's that's pretty much for me
i've always like i said i've always had
that natural
fit through
you know
that voice telling me like hey uh no
this ain't good this ain't for you you
know
yeah
you know what
i'm gonna do for the third time
i'm gonna invite your brother
to my class inshaallah
uh because i know that that will
actually i think honestly in a way might
be better than learning everything for
you because
inshallah you're learning your deen
inshallah
so i will hit you up on instagram
inshaallah so we can get that sorted out
may allah bless you mostly bro allah is
a beautiful story
all bless your family as well
your brothers and sisters are muslim
i mean and if there's anyone that you
love you care but that's not muslim may
allah through you uh and bless you
immensely
and to this
it's not better than
learning arabic it's it's equal
you should do it alongside and like you
said in the previous video
yeah i agree i want to say that i mean
like short term because like
like from the first class inshallah i
think it will start to transform the
brother
i want to be able to you know my goal is
is to be able to
start reading quran
you know
if straight ought to be if i can you
know
i have both my english and then i have
the arabic version and you know
uh most of the videos and studying i i
watch they say hey you know it's
it's better if you recite it and you
know the natural language that it was
you know delivered upon
prophet mohammed something
100 and that that definitely is true and
i do agree with him 100 that uh it will
insha allah you know be very very
beneficial
he said wednesdays right
yeah wednesdays 7 to 9 eastern standard
time
okay perfect
oh all right that that'll be it for me
brothers i really appreciate the time um
all right anytime y'all
do a live
y'all need me on up i'll be there
because
sister probably didn't know that her mic
was on and you can honor yourself when
you feel good
yeah i'm ready to go
all right
so i think there was a there's an issue
you kept coming in and out of the the
stream
yeah i think that's it we're gonna wrap
it up in like five minutes anyway
anything else that you had a question or
you wanted to discuss
feel free
uh yeah i also just wanted to i don't
know i guess like shout out to i've been
hearing a couple other people recently
a couple other sisters like wanting to
start a podcast or show that's something
i've been wanting to do too so if anyone
wants to connect over that that'd be
cool and
if you guys have any advice with regards
to specifically like determining what
type like what topics
would be
relevant and helpful
um i would say for me the first and best
thing i would recommend is
formulating your intention in in terms
of your target audience right
for us me rami and angel
we're young we're dealing with issues
that that young men and women alike are
dealing with and we were having these
conversations anyway
for a long time and and and we we
realized at one point we were like
if we would have hit record
and
even if it was just one more person
right we didn't care about the views or
the subs or anything like that but if
one more person
would have just heard this
just imagine how much it would have
benefited them because how much it
benefited us right
and that's what essentially gave us our
intention
or go ahead green light that
just hit record don't be scripted don't
worry about all you know obviously
there's things we keep in mind and all
this and
um but tldr we just talk about what we
want to talk about anyway and
that's what we're doing today and
they're issues that the youth are
suffering with their issues that
um
the newer generation they're they're
they're kind of you know being stretched
out thin
between the parental generation and then
there's also this new new generation
which is just like
you know just waste and and this whole
new tic-tac culture and all this fashion
so they're kind of stuck between this
right it's almost like some of them are
born into
families where they find themselves
trying to you know guide their families
and their elders right and and kind of
be a role model for them essentially and
kind of even help their parents but then
also be ready to raise the new
generation right so this is our target
audience inshallah and and this is i
would say
once you have this target audience
very easy and simple says to come up
with podcast you know topics and stuff
like that people are gonna reach out
you'll know what your audience likes and
that's all i gotta say
do you ever feel like i don't know
sometimes i just worry like
not being
i guess the most knowledgeable person i
don't want to
say thing talk about things i don't know
about or i feel like i have to do like
hours of research for one episode type
of thing on her bro
you've been awfully quiet would you do
the honor
of telling her how we exactly relate to
this
and what we talked about
yeah before we started our podcast
i was the one who said you know i don't
feel like we know enough
i think we should do more research first
learn more
first at least several years you know
have better understanding before we
make these videos and
the thing is like we're never going to
be perfect
we're never going to have
the right
amount of knowledge of the right amount
of insight or wisdom
at the end of the day it's like if you
feel this calling if you feel like allah
is pulling you
to do this
with several other sisters i mean you
even mention yourself that you're
looking for friends so
maybe this might be a poo in that
direction you are
not only going to give dawah
but you're also going to be making some
lifelong
sisters some lifelong friends
so
yes
it's you feel the pull you go with it
you know if allah says move you move you
don't question it
and if if you don't know well then you
learn
it's as simple as that
i also wanted to say something because i
know rami has some thoughts too that
there's nothing wrong with starting and
just making a difference while you still
can there's a difference between doing
that cis and just
talking ignorantly do you know what i
mean so definitely start
and start before you know start sooner
than later it's definitely better to
start than not start at all but
simultaneously you know you're never
going to get there some of the greatest
scholars of islam they were asked you
know at the very final moments of their
of their lives what what do you regret
what would you like to do differently
what do you wish would have happened
differently and they were like if only i
started sooner
these are men that
studied islam for 80
60 to 80 years
and that's what they were saying so
you're never going to get that you're
never going to be as good as you think
you want to be and that's not to
discourage you from obviously seeking
element and knowledge and all that but
start somewhere and
if anything when me rami and angel when
the brothers we were faced with all
these reflections and paradigm shifts
like do we really not know enough
we decided okay why not continue doing
what we're doing but just continue
learning now and really amp it up
100
uh my only thoughts firstly
we'll be attending them
a lot of times
we'd love to have you back on multiple
times
but back on this topic sister
uh i want to all i want to add because
the brothers gave i think beautiful
answer so i don't want to talk too much
but what i want to add is that uh you're
not you're not asked to be a scholar you
don't have you don't have to be a
scholar you're not a scholar um and most
people unfortunately i will say will
never be scholars and that's not
something that is you know
uh
bad for the person or wrong for the
person
just follow the simple principle that if
you know you will share because the
prophet
he said
convey from me even if it's just one
ayah
but i don't i don't want to miss calling
one so i won't say it's a quote but
one of the best things to do
or maybe 90 of what you're going to do
they say that you don't know and that's
okay there's beauty in saying i don't
know because if you don't know let me go
find out you go find out you learn you
expand your knowledge you become better
over time and i think that's the same
old story for honestly all of us
and it will be the same for you and you
know not everything is about knowledge
and i think that's what a lot of people
forget a lot of people miss out on it's
not always about knowledge sometimes
it's just about demeanor confidence and
kind of playing the role because i'm
going to be honest sister if the three
of us me and fried and he'll make a
video for the sisters about the sisters
and you and a group of sisters make the
same exact video yours is going to do
better yours is going to be more
received or you know better received
than ours just because you're a sister
and that's why i say we need more
sisters in the dawah and that's why i
encourage sisters to uh you know follow
take out the mental and be the
the exemplary example for other sisters
out there
yeah
i think for the sake of
having like being able to watch your
guys's podcast has helped me so much um
becoming closer to the dean as well and
like it would be so nice to have
something
where
women of islam share our genuine
experiences as well so i feel like
i think it would be worth it try and
push past those fears
yeah it definitely would
i think the last thing that i want to
say is that
when you do start doing this you know
you and the sisters do what you can
have conversations
going on certain things
and you'll see like the more you learn
the more you understand the more wisdom
you have the more insight you have
allah will increase the barakah allah
will increase the outreach
because it wasn't honestly it wasn't
until
me romney and fire began to really like
go deeper into
learning more and you know may love
bless ron because he was the first one
that was already in it before us
but it wasn't until all three of us made
that
intention together so like really start
going
deeper into the studies
and going deeper into islam
and then i don't know where we started
receiving buttercup and like we could
attribute this
to
you know putting out more content
hitting things that are more trending
and all that stuff but at the end of the
day like everything happens by leave of
allah and it wasn't until we made that
intention so like hey i'm not saying
that that's what it was i'm just saying
like i'm putting two and two together
and it just makes sense so
my insight is that you know just
do your thing
and keep learning as you go and you'll
see allah
just increase everything that you and
the sisters are doing
tenfold
you'll see inshallah
yeah there's one more thing that i
thought or two more things actually uh
and kind of first one's piggybacking off
of what angel said i definitely believe
uh it'll be more beneficial for you and
the sisters
on the podcast than it will be for the
audience i honestly think me myself i
think i have benefited more from this
podcast than the viewers and that's not
just saying that i learned from
unhealthy and we learn from each other
that's saying that holding yourself
accountable putting yourself in a
position of accountability and all of
that responsibility pushes you to levels
you never thought that you could reach
and that in and of itself i think is a
huge blessing from allah and if that's
your responsibility you take on that
mantle it'll you know push you further
insha allah the second thing i want to
say is
think that you're not knowledgeable or
whatever and there's a topic that's
scary do what we do bring on someone who
knows
allah says if you don't know go to those
who know that's it you don't know a
topic you want to talk about it bring
someone on uh a sister honor maybe a
brother on
if it's a shaykh i think would be good
as well or would be even better in my
opinion and have them talk about
inshallah from the quran in the sunnah
and that'll put you i think miles ahead
yeah that's really helpful too
all right with that being said i think
we got one last uh
chat
all right thank you guys so much
all right we're gonna we're gonna
address that later uh yeah and why yeah
this was a pleasure having you
and until next time guys if you made it
this far smash the like button what are
you doing we got like 150 viewers on the
live stream we should have at least 700
likes right now
and uh look forward to the live stream
with sheikh with one event
on friday inshallah 7 p.m eastern
standard time uh 11 59 p.m uk time gmt
and with that being said army do your
thing
that being said we're ending the stream
bro
we're ending the stream bro come on it's
been an hour and a half all right
bless you all of that
foreign